regardez ce joli petit pont donc on va
voir ce qui va nous réserver de beau
un nouvel élément alors il arrive en
pêche à l'aimant de perdre des aimants
souvent c'est dans l'eau nous c'est un
peu différent en fait on est rentré un
jour de la pêche et plus dément tu l'as
mis où je sais pas peut-être on nous l'a
volé du coup un grand merci à maison de
la détection donc bien sûr c'est un
élément Barbarian on pêche plus qu'avec
ça donc c'est les plus gros 1600 kg de
force
[Musique]
ça va être parfait tout neuf tout propre
tout lisse bien puissant bien puissant
de quoi c'est surtout pas vos doigts
entre les mains et le deuxième aimant
sinon vous pouvez dire au revoir à vos
petites phalanges bon assez parlé
j'espère que tu as pas oublié le
tournevis pour serrer hein
jusqu'au bout
on met pas le joint il y en a qui le
mette bon
il y en a qui met du silicone ou de la
colle aussi pour le figer nous on le
fait pas il va avoir peut-être un peu de
jeu au début il va attendre avoir
tendance à un peu se desserrer faudra
checker mais sinon il y a pas de souci
quoi et puis bon on pêche à plusieurs
aimants donc si on le perd on pourra le
repêcher c'est aussi ça le truc
comme ça est-ce qu'il va y arriver après
il peut passer les mains
[Musique]
en fait ça suffit
alors regardons ce que l'on peut trouver
avec cet aimant surpuissant de chez
Maison de la détection et neuf surtout
regardez le bien il sera plus jamais
comme ça
[Musique]
il y a un truc
oh c'est une canne à pêche ah ben voilà
Océane
regarde tu voulais une canne à pêche
il y a tout ce qu'il faut tu as le
moulinet et tout quoi
une canne à pêche
[Musique]
j'ai attrapé un poisson en plus attends
on va voir
il est pas beau il est pas beau mon
poisson mais il est beau
[Musique]
allez
décrypte le code
avec un peu de chance tu le fermes et
c'est le bon code
si tu fais en direct et que ça marche
bah tu as le code bah voilà non 2016
le code
tu es content
allez vas-y sans nous
[Musique]
une vitre de pénis
attends mais c'était du double vitrage
[Musique]
de péniche ah oui ah oui tu as raison
ouais c'est une vitre de la cabine
c'est beau incroyable
regardez ça peut-être un peu dangereux
du coup là
tu vas tomber
j'ai un truc assez lourd
voilà un panneau
petit panneau
du coup c'est pas fait ici non c'est pas
fait
pourquoi c'est pas non plus rempli
[Musique]
c'est juste
il y en a un autre là-bas
je pense que c'est une sorte de pompe
ça c'est un leurre de pêche pour retirer
les poissons ils essaient de les gober
et après ils se prennent l'hameçon dans
la bouche pour les gros hein
[Musique]
pas mal c'est pas si vieux
c'est bizarre ça
ce soir
journaliste nous abandonne
[Musique]
oui la forme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un vrai nom
changement d'avis
[Musique]
on vient de franchir un pont
c'était très bizarre en passant et on a
frotté et là je viens de repasser à pied
déjà il y a pas mal de trous mais voilà
voilà sur quoi on a roulé
clairement ça aurait pu faire une dingue
grille là donc du coup c'est là qui
tient pas
une deuxième
et franchement
c'est chaud
et là on a frotté
j'espère qu'il y a un autre chemin
comment on peut faire un péniche
une péniche
déjà elles sont dans le bon sens
maintenant
vas-y c'est pour ça qu'on trouve des
fenêtres de pénis après Baptiste
exactement c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé tout ce qui a une petite
reconstitution
mais ça va être très drôle
[Musique]
tu seras sur Facebook
vous mettez un objet qui pisse dans sa
voiture regarde ah oui et alors c'est
horrible
allez monte en voiture on part
ah oui quand même
[Musique]
un aimant je crois
que c'est un aimant
même dans les quoi les plus paumés
il est encore en bon état
c'est pas mal ça fait un bon souvenir
S
il marche
pas trop le casse pas regarde
je sais même pas
ouais si je pense voilà on roulait à
côté du canal du coup on a une idée on
va essayer de traîner un peu les mains
et roule ma poule allez donne-moi la clé
ah merde j'ai oublié ce détail bon on
sort
ça va neiger
il est déjà dans le port
[Musique]